in a special edition of the dish we meet
the chef behind some of the most
inventive Italian cuisine on both coasts
Casey Lane is a four-time semifinalist
for the James Beard Foundation's rising
star chef award GQ called his first
eatery one of the best 10 best new
restaurants in America and food and wine
says Lane is dominating late-night
dining in LA we sat down with him at two
of his popular restaurants both located
inside newly built hotels not bad for a
chef still in the early years of his
career so you are a little superstitious
about all the success at such an early
age
I mean I just felt out of place most of
the time why because we didn't like go
the path of that everyone's traveled we
didn't do the big-name chef the big-name
restaurant the big-name company behind
you we kind of just did it ourselves
that do-it-yourself attitude was the key
to success for 35 year-old Casey Lane
one of LA's most prolific chefs and now
owner of the new viale de Romani
a West Hollywood favorite the Romani are
kind of like the transient people
throughout Italy a lot of like Pakistani
a lot of Vinny on north africans we
wanted it to be a bit of you know the
way of the gypsies the result southern
italian cuisine with a twist
this is billed though as an Italian
restaurant
but I see these Spanish and North
African influences like how does that
marinate I think it it marinates was
like the change in time you know the way
that Italy is not only Italians now you
know there are a lot of other people
that live breathe eat their shop their
you know own stores the menu includes
dishes like falafel checchina
and saffron sauteed rice with clams
sauteed Rice's are hard not to be my
favorite we wanted to create a menu of
things that really not a lot of other
people offer viale do Romani is the main
dining room of the new Lapeer hotel
where Lane shows off with firepower you
look like you're enjoying this
I really like this I really like cooking
with fire the wood-fired oven Pizza has
been called some of the best in the city
and it's Quattro formaggio topped with
chanterelle mushrooms is a must order we
made a pretty little pie didn't they're
pretty yeah Cheers
when did you discover this is my passion
I want to be a chef I loved the idea of
families having dinner together you know
that was like when I was 5 years old
cooking with my grandfather was the only
way he could get like all of my aunts
and uncles around the same table
together because they were all
20-somethings and there was five of them
and they were out all over the place and
I saw the way that they would come when
he cooked and I really really liked that
Lane fell in love with baking in
Portland the city's fine dining
institution Clark Lewis he then headed
south to Los Angeles to open the tasting
kitchen one of the toughest reservations
along Venice's Abbot Kinney Boulevard
why does it work it was 2009 so for
almost ten years ago and there was a
recession right and everyone was wanting
to go like real rustic and simple and
cheap and there was a part of me that's
always been like well if everyone's
gonna create a cacophony over here let's
let's kind of walk with a different path
and so we did we open kind of a
higher-end dining house like dinner
house we are going to do only whole
animal butchery we are going to cure
we're going to make all of the breads
we're gonna make all the pasta we're
gonna do every single thing by hand your
gut said go against the grain go big or
go home
handcrafted handcrafted and we're gonna
be nice we're gonna be really nice
people we're gonna have a lot of
humility inside of us like always
remembering that we're so excited to
have the people who come enjoy what
we're doing Lane's big on up-and-coming
neighborhoods from Venice to West
Hollywood and now downtown Los Angeles
when I was growing up here this was
basically Skid Row it it is definitely
like progressed for sure I mean behind
us we have LeBron James playing
basketball now
Museum when Nokia's there and then we
have this beautiful building that was
you know one of the older hotels in Los
Angeles his latest venture is inside the
restored Hotel Figueroa the specialty
the dry ice is gonna chill the gin down
before I add the soda a gin and tonic
that's otherworldly it kind of releases
a little bit of the aromas Pancho's or
small bites accompany the experience
inspired by lanes travels through bass
country we have a sea urchin flan spiced
potato chips we have bacon-wrapped dates
one of my favorite things on planet but
Brava the hotel's restaurant anchor is
the culinary showcase good
that's a bronzy no good here from fish
two heaping plates of paia
I find that everyone has so much fun
with my air because you really get to
make your own dish out of it so I sense
that every restaurant has a little bit
of something from they share very red
yeah yeah for sure I mean I think that
any good brand in the world cheers a red
thread right in it always kind of ties
together like a group of products or you
know offerings that somehow have a very
similar kind of feel to them but lanes
got even bigger fish on the fryer well I
think Lane Lane Lane Lane we will we
will definitely will definitely get to
the points where River who already do
you know just launched a few small
properties that are you know very dear
to us and whatever happens from there
well god bless it but we want to do them
right it'll be fun I tell you one thing
though this hummus is amazing Michelle
where's the food again
you didn't bring one of those gin and
tonics with the dry ice demon out I'm
sorry he's amazing I gotta go I got that
I gotta go that looks so good Wow Lane